if your boyfriend likes photos and
videos of girls with huge butts on the
internet I think this video is for you
hi I'm Michaela I have a fat boy
and I will happily block your boyfriend
if you ask me but that's not why I'm
here why I'm here is to tell you the
story of how I got like this because I'm
just like you by the way I have Clay all
over me but my ex-boyfriend would like
photos of Jeanette Guzman the Instagram
model I think he actually only liked
like five photos total but when I
discovered this and we had just started
dating when I discovered this I would
cry every night I would devalue myself I
have BPD by the way I'll devalue myself
I am not good enough I am not a good
enough person because I don't have a fat
butt and I don't have every single
surgery that Janette Guzman has so I'm
not good enough and this went on for a
long time I was very insecure and I
became very very sad and I just hated
who I was I hated myself so what did I
do I tried everything in the books I
tried everything I possibly could do to
look like Jeanette Guzman and I think
I've done a pretty good job I think I
did a decent job but now
now this dude is gone and apparently his
type is completely freaking different to
anything I am so I did all this for
nothing you're telling me I got surgery
that I can't reverse
just for the man to go have a different
height no that's on you
that's on you
let me tell you a little something
your ex-boyfriend was looking at
pictures and liking pictures of who with
a big butt
cool you decided to look at that
it's like if I was looking at my girl's
prawn history
and she
likes dude with
humongous
I'm talking about 12.
15.
I don't have a 12 50 inch I don't
absolutely don't
and then I proceed to oh man that's a
fantasy
if the person's with you and he likes
other things it doesn't mean that it's
exactly that what was up that's her
that's the girl that she's looking at
Jeanette Guzman
you can imagine your uh Instagram yeah
whatever it doesn't matter it's like
it's just you doing all those changes is
not
you doing all those changes to to
pleasure your boy
is not on your boy it's on you
it's it's on you
okay
him liking those pictures while he's
going out with you
oh it [ __ ] up with your self-esteem and
stuff like that I can understand that
but it's let's just let's just say it
loud and listen to yourself when you say
it
self-esteem a choice
it's yours
it's your self-esteem
all right and if he likes those pictures
and that's a fetish or that's a fantasy
it stays a fantasy all right it doesn't
mean that that's what he wants or
whatever that's exactly what he craved
no he likes the picture wait wait you're
saying my girl doesn't want me to become
a vampire no
no that's actually what I I'm saying yep
so all those girls who were like getting
super wet Over The Vampire Diaries or
Twilight that wasn't supposed to change
into looking like them did you I was
wondering I'm just asking I'm just
asking
it's liking it's it's a
fantasy the same way some of you women
even though you're super feminist
fantasize about a whole bunch of [ __ ]
that are not so feminists
when you're in the sheets
and that's fine it doesn't mean that's
what you want in real life it stays in
the realm of fantasy doesn't mean I
don't have to not like it there's fan
fiction of whatever what not that
doesn't mean it has to happen so for you
to take that
and change your whole body
and after that you but your ex is gone
and then he likes something different
and you still blaming for that
mental health whoa I don't think it's
that abnormal I think um
we'll probably see like beauty standards
changing and if you have insecurities in
yourself already off the top and you see
your boyfriend is looking at those kinds
of women and you're uncertain and you're
insecure stance the reason you might
think he'll want someone like that yeah
but maybe women feel that way if you
look if I you take
the girls that you if you look at the
guy that your girl like
we would not be happy any
do I [ __ ] look like Brad Pitt
you know what I would have to do and
endure to [ __ ] remotely look like
Brad Pitt I can't do that I'm not gonna
change if I see my girl liking the
picture of Brad Pitt I can't be like
I'ma look I'ma be Brad Pitt and change
my hair blonde and that's [ __ ] yeah
but okay here's an example but do got a
small dick and getting with a girl she's
like no small dicks are fine but she
looking at Dick's with big big dicks
yeah the dude's probably gonna be
terribly insecure probably and I know
plenty of dudes if they could they would
change it in a heartbeat I can
understand that you know so those are
ideas and insecurities and then going
for what you think your partner actually
wants based off what they like online
these are far-fetched but if I
understand that but if you go for it you
can't blame
you took the decision I have a hard time
blaming the other person for Life yeah I
agree with you I did I did this whole
big thing for you no you wanted a dick
you wanted a dick yeah yeah Bobby I
don't know if she's actually blaming him
I think she's just saying you know like
oh so you change so like this whole
thing what was the point of it I don't
think she actually blame him if she's
saying
I'm not with this guy and uh yeah it's a
totally different uh a type
so I did all this for nothing
yeah you're kind of blaming that's bling
that's you somehow somewhere blinging
him for some things
anyway this is
completely irreversible so the more
weight I gain the fat of my butt gets
and there's nothing I can do to stop it
it is just constantly growing
and today I was getting bubble tea
Alicia would you want to tell them the
story I was getting bubble tea today and
some lady on drugs uh came up to me and
was like so you like the way you look
this is why young girls and just gave me
the and I just burst into tears I
bursted into tears because I was I was
that young girl okay and I became this
and this is not what I want to advertise
to anyone going to be so controversial
but people that do this to themselves
are mentally ill if we don't if we say
we don't we're lying
obviously not for everyone but if you're
in that boat you know what boat I'm
talking about
cancel that surgery
because one the trend is going to be
gone in a few years two it hurts it's
very painful and costs a lot of money
and three you will regret it because
that man is going to be calm and then
you'll be stuck with a freaking dump
truck that you can't get rid of and get
screened down on the street by old
ladies yeah I don't think you're just
nearly blaming him nearly as much she's
not only by me him yeah you're right it
didn't sound like she's being like I
think it was just renting is like I did
this for somebody and then he went off
and changed his type like what was the
point of everything I did maybe you
didn't change his time maybe maybe I
think what she's basically saying is she
put a lot of pressure on herself and
basically her insecurities came out that
she made decisions that were really
[ __ ] stupid and then she said update
you're mentally ill like you got a
sickness if you're gonna do all of this
dude so you have United marry or
anything you're just gonna change
everything up the the and
gave me the accountability that I
thought she didn't have yeah
so I'll give you that yeah I'm sorry
about yeah what I said I think what it
really just speaks to I think the big
thing with this is that people feel so
much pressure to appeal to the opposite
sex and the links that they have to go
through sometimes have superseded
anything we thought was ever possible
that's crazy they go on they're spending
hundreds of thousands of dollars going
up in the knife literally changing their
whole face losing any cultural heritage
they ever had before whatever your
parents today cutting that [ __ ] up yeah
okay looking like a whole different
human being okay because you know one
thing that's really weird about all
these is like they all start to look the
same yes you look at their face and
you're like I don't know where are you
from because your nose is from Siberia
but your booty from Angola I don't know
and it's a weird combination I know what
you're from
Instagram
might as well could be for Atlantis for
all I know because I don't know any
place where everybody's got the same
look other than Instagram
so
to me this is just sad like yeah she's
talking about mental illness and how
like you have to be so deeply sick and
not like in this sense that you have BPD
but like there's something really sick
in our society where folks have to go
through this much change and people like
oh I'm doing it from
they're not most they're not doing for
themselves where are you from Montreal
Canada where are you from Mobile Alabama
where are you from filters Instagram
that's that's where she from filters
Instagram folks that's where a lot of
people were from folks are not doing it
for themselves they're doing it because
there's a beauty standard and they're
adhering to it that's why folks are
getting the ass done because I wasn't
the beauty standard before I heard
nobody trying to get their ass done 20
years ago in the 90s nobody none but
they're doing it now because that's
what's in
so all this talk about doing it's like
even if you're saying you're doing it
for yourself you know what you're pretty
much influencing the idea was given to
you by Society so you can't separate the
two so we
have to think about like what is the
long-term implication is going to be for
these people who have these surgeries
and get old life what is it going to be
like for them I don't think we really
reckon with that what is a bbr look like
in old age
it doesn't take long for it not to look
good
it don't look yeah you don't need 40
years no no to look
like a bag of marbles you don't you
don't need a it's not a lot yes you know
the life expectancy of a BBL is seven to
ten years
amen and then gravity gravitates you
know so to anybody who's watching right
now people a lot of folks are
considering it or want to get it done or
want to look like a certain type of
thing understand oftentimes whatever
Pros that you have in the short term
don't outweigh the cons that you have in
the long term and me parts I don't know
how you guys feel me personally when I
see those faces that are like perfectly
symmetrical with the same [ __ ] notes
and everybody I don't find that
appealing because it looks really weird
to me even though I can understand why
it's aesthetically pleasing and a lot of
guys are going for me and just
there's no flavor it's just it's
unfortunate and
more than anything watching this video
is like yeah her situation seems sad so
that's what I was thinking about it but
I was glad she spoke about it candidly
and when she said about stuff about the
egg and she just was like yeah I did it
for a dude that was candid no
it wasn't candid it's not my definition
of cancer what's your Felicity candidate
well you know all happiness and
everything and stuff it's like you know
it's a thing it's not a thing you know a
kid that normally he's like just
straight up
that's the definition of candid yeah
okay yeah so we'll say Candid Camera
those are way of saying like a real
reflection of what the person looks like
take it informally so it's meant to be
like yeah moment of what's happening so
you're not ready for the phone yeah it's
kind of thing so but anyways
um you know
yeah let us know what you guys think
below what did you guys think about your
story how did you guys feeling and for
ladies who are watching like yo do you
guys feel pressured for this and [ __ ]
have you done it have you not do you
regret it do you feel really happy about
it she did all of that [ __ ] for a guy
most of them I'll do all that [ __ ]
Mac hubby Hey listen most people do all
that [ __ ] for a girl or for a guy
you're not wrong
you're not wrong it's not that abnormal
you're not wrong that's why
that's why because I'm like I know
plenty of dudes
getting hair transplants doing whatever
for the opposite sex fair you know
whether it's one person who's particular
or a bunch of dudes it's like they're
doing it because
they feel they need to to be that thing
right so yeah but anyways we want to
hear from you guys what do you guys